all right teds we've got some new snow
on the spring mountains means more
driving dangers if you're going to be
heading out that way for example a car
rolled over several others were stuck
this morning that according to Nevada
State Police Ryan mathey joins us now
with what is being done to minimize
those dangers
well the route up here is definitely
getting Slimmer you can see just over
here the snow being plowed off to the
side limiting any available shoulder
space you can see this car coming by
right now with how narrow this passage
may be but despite those obstacles
skiers keep on coming we're starting
March off correctly 36 inches within 48
Hours says Lee Canyon Ski Resort
director of marketing Jim Seeley the
quick window of snowfall that we had you
know it's really important to continue
that mitigation checking the snowpack
seeing how stable it is and you know
doing the necessary mitigation
he's expecting more crowds every weekend
this March day passes just 25 every
Friday to benefit a non-profit for
injured athletes but is there enough
space for everyone because it is so
crowded it's a very limited space up
there the concerns of go Mount
Charleston a partner of the U.S forest
Service who plows snow alongside Clark
County and ndot program manager Rosa
praser says capacity along Sr 156 and
157 are increasingly hitting weekend
capacity by nine in the morning during
that Peak Thursday morning Nevada state
police reported a one-hour closure of
the 156 when a vehicle rolled over on
the icy roads one person sent to the
hospital we call it fishtailing where
your back end of your vehicle will start
to move and you can spin out it really
ends up being no place to park that's
the biggest issue you know you're
obviously not the only one that has the
idea so everyone does come up
Ryan thanks for that the ski resort
anticipates this weekend specifically to
be very busy with all that new snow
coming in if you don't have a
reservation you could be waiting in line
until a car comes out of the parking lot
go Mount Charleston wants you to keep
your car full of gas food water blankets
and a shovel just in case he gets stuck